good morning Nick it's Tuesday I want to
talk today about what's going on in the
Central African Republic but first a
couple preparatory notes one in the US
especially we tend to imagine Africa
monolithically as like poor and
undeveloped and generally other even
though it is a large continent full of
vastly different nations and while today
we're going to talk about an african
state that has struggled more or less
continually since its independence it's
worth remembering that seven of the
world's ten fastest-growing economies
are in Africa - this is speculation but
I think one of the reasons we don't hear
about what's going on in the Central
African Republic is that it's
complicated you know we like narratives
like the rebels versus the Empire or
Perry versus Voldemort or Dora versus
Swiper the Fox I'm sorry I watch a lot
of children's TV like we can stand some
shades of grey and our heroes and our
villains but we love to know who the
heroes are and who the villains are and
I think a lot of times when news stories
don't fit that narrative we just ignore
them because the ideal good guys and bad
guys is so central to our understanding
of ourselves and our world that we can't
abandon it and I also think if I can
tangent on a tangent that this is part
of why our interest lags when
international news stories grow like
less narrative ly powerful like it's
easy to root for the rebels in Cairo's
Tahrir Square when they want freedom and
democracy but the actual complex
business of rebuilding a state as we've
seen in Egypt and elsewhere gets
somewhat less attention okay with all
that noted the Central African Republic
is here in you guessed it the center of
Africa although to be fair it has not
often been much of a republic life
expectancy in the sea AR is 51 and it's
one of the poorest countries in the
world today so after declaring
independence from France in 1960 there
were several decades of military rule
but then in 1993 there were multi-party
elections and the elected president was
on Felix pad to say and initially the
economy grew under fantasy but he failed
to be able to pay the military and civil
servants which is like one of the
central things that governments do also
there was quite a bit of corruption and
there were several coup attempts over
the next decade so POTUS say remain
president until 2003 when a military
coup finally succeeded military leader
Francois Bozize they succeeded by using
the time-honored tactic of waiting until
the president was out of town and then
quickly seizing the government so
obviously the CIA are has long struggled
with security and political stability
like in the east of the country the
Lord's Resistance Army led by Joseph
Kony whom you might remember from his
brief moment of Kony 2012 internet fame
yeah that guy his group has been
murdering and torturing people for
decades in fact it's believed by many
that Kony is hiding out in the Central
African Republic but also both the fat
si and Bozize a regimes relied on
foreign armies from Chad and the
Democratic Republic of Congo and
elsewhere to help like shore up their
governments but security was after
Bozize a took power in 2003 things got
significantly worse so there was this
group the union of democratic forces for
unity that combined with other rebel
groups and began to fight against Bozize
aids regime in what came to be known as
the Central African bush war this
involved lots of groups like the
People's Army for the restoration of
democracy and a convention of Patriots
for justice and peace but anyway they
all banded together and tried to take
down the government it didn't work
finally there was a peace treaty in 2007
but the fighting never like totally
stopped
okay so flash forward to 2012 several of
the groups in the Central African bush
war unite with some other rebel groups
to form salika which means Union and
most members of salika belong to the CA
ours Muslim minority which is about 15%
of the country's population they put me
taking 12 a bunch of towns in the north
in the centre and then other African
countries including Chad send in troops
to try to protect the capital of bangy
but it doesn't work so in March 2013 the
capital of the Central African Republic
Bangi Falls to these silicon rebels and
Bozize a flees the country and one of
Silica's leaders a Muslim Michele Johto
job becomes president but almost as soon
as silica takes power there's a lot of
infighting among all of these groups
that formed the Union like it's easy to
unify when you're all battling the
government but then when you have the
power everybody kind of wants some of
the power meanwhile there was never
anything approaching peace and salika
militias committed all kinds of
atrocities like according to Human
Rights Watch they burn dozens of towns
and villages they shot fleeing civilians
in the back and also a huge percentage
of the population has been displaced
there are tens of thousands of
Christians who fled to the Bunge Airport
and remained there for months and now we
come to the Christian anti-balaka or
anti sword militias these anti-balaka
groups have sought to respond to silly
cos violence with much more violence and
the anti-balaka mass murder of members
of the Muslim minority is now being
called by many a genocide or at least
the beginning of one so in January 2014
President Joe Tojo resigned and was
replaced by a woman named Catherine
Samba Ponza but there is
currently much of a government to lead
in the Central African Republic last
week the UN approved an 11,000 member
security force that will hopefully bring
an end to the violence but for now it
continues Hank like I said earlier this
conflict is difficult and complicated
and it looks nothing like you know
hobbits versus Sauron
but that isn't only the case in the
Central African Republic I mean who were
the good guys in the American Revolution
the Americans were for freedom and
democracy right well yeah except for
slaves who probably would have been much
better off under the rule of England but
what about the Vietnam War or the French
Revolution or world war one in which so
many people died for so little hey we
can't just ignore stories that don't fit
our understanding of the world and we
also shouldn't try to like change them
to make them fit our preconceived
narratives of humanity we have to make
room in our stories for the world as we
find it and the Central African Republic
reminds us that war is not finally a
story of good versus evil as much as we
might wish it were so let's hope the UN
peacekeepers arrive soon and can live up
to their name I'll see you on Friday